president biden and his top staffers
continue to lie about endemic american
racism
prosecutors declined to charge a cop in
the death of ashley babbitt while moving
forward with charges against a cop in
the death of dante wright
and the activist media moved to pressure
corporations to echo the racial
resentment politics of the democratic
party i'm ben shapiro this is the ben
shapiro show
[Music]
the benjamin shapiro show is sponsored
by expressvpn protect your online
privacy today at expressvpn.com
ben well joe biden was elected to be not
donald trump that was the main mandate
for joe biden his mandate was not to
completely remodel america his mandate
was not
to act like bernie sanders on economics
or to act like louis farrakhan on race
and yet this is exactly what we've been
getting from the biden administration
his top appointees have all been echoing
the nicole hannah jones ta-nehisi coates
nonsense about how america is rooted in
endemic racism
and that it is the job of the biden
administration to completely remake
all of america's institutions in a mold
of equity
and this is the critical racial theory
nonsense is the idea that all of the
institutions of america are shot through
with racism
and tearing them out at the root and
replacing them with something more
equitable
namely top-down government control
seeking equality of outcome
rather than equality of enforcement of
rights that should be the goal
and every day it becomes clear that this
is what biden is up to which is an
incredible thing because again this guy
is a
lifelong semi-corrupt politician
whose entire career has basically been
putting his finger in the wind on a
variety of issues
ranging from abortion to criminal
justice reform and this is a guy who is
in favor
of locking up criminals until he was
very much against locking up criminals
this is a person who's against busting
until he was quasi in favor of busing
this is a person who used to be kind of
anti-abortion until he was super
pro-abortion
and joe biden is not the person you
would go to for a principled stand and
yet here he is
staffing up his administration with a
bunch of radicals who have extremely
principled stands all of their
principles are wrong
but their stands are extremely
principled and
not at all or in any way moderate the
latest example of this is u.n ambassador
linda thomas greenfield so she is a
biden appointee
and remember this is the un ambassador
this is the person who speaks for the
united states on the world stage so
under donald trump
this is people like nikki haley there's
people who went to the u.n and basically
told all the other countries on earth
we're the united states our value system
is indeed superior and you really ought
to give us a listen
meanwhile you have the biden
administration trotting out to the u.n a
person who says that america
is steeped in bigotry and racism that
america is a terrible place
here is linda thomas greenfield the u.n
ambassador
speaking to the national action network
which of course is al sharpton's group
by the way
it remains a source of astonishment to
me that al sharpton is well accepted in
the halls of democratic power
for a bunch of folks who say they really
don't like race riots they seem to
be kind of okay with it when it's al
sharpton promoting it in any case
here was linda thomas greenfield
speaking to the national action network
and explaining
that the united states is a deeply
racist place founded in racism with
founding principles shot through with
racism
i grew up in the segregated south i was
bussed to a segregated school
on weekends the klan burned crosses on
lawns in our neighborhood
i shared these stories and others to
acknowledge on the international stage
that i have personally experienced one
of america's greatest
imperfections i've seen for myself how
the original sin
of slavery weaved white supremacy
into our founding documents and
principles we wove white supremacy into
our founding documents and principles
this is precisely the opposite the
opposite of what frederick douglass
an actual former slave suggested in the
lead-up to the civil war when he said
that the constitution of the united
states is a liberty document
and the problem was that the promissory
note of the declaration of independence
had not been fulfilled for black
americans but the foundational
principles of the united states were
indeed universal
it's precisely the opposite of this that
is being promoted now by the biden
administration what she is saying there
is so despicable to say that on the
world stage is so dis
i mean that's what she's saying she said
on the international stage i go around
to countries like china
which is extraordinary human rights
oppressor or iran and i tell them that
i've experienced depression in the
united states on the basis of race
not because there are evil people who
misinterpret america's founding
documents
not because america has a fraught
history with race that is filled with
darkness and that we have overcome
gradually and with tremendous success
statistically speaking
no what i say is that america's founding
principles the principles we still stand
upon
are shot through with white supremacy
she also added
quote racism is the problem of the
racist and it is the problem of the
society that produces
the racist and in today's world that's
every society
right so if there is a racist in the
united states that's because of society
producing
that racist the society itself is evil
and cruel
she also said that she believes white
supremacy was the key factor that led
police to kill both george floyd
and brianna taylor last year again there
is zero evidence i mean
zero evidence that george floyd was
killed because of his race not
one person has brought a single shred of
evidence to suggest that he was killed
because of his race
it's simply a conjectural point brought
out by people on the left who want to
back a narrative that every time a black
person dies at the hands of a white cop
or is involved with a white cop because
we don't even know at this point given
the medical evidence whether george
floyd died because of derek chovan at
all
anytime there's a situation involving a
white cop and a black person who dies in
custody
it must be because of endemic american
racism same thing with brianna taylor is
there evidence that brianna taylor had
been white she would still be alive
where is the evidence on that
considering that fire blindly
threw the through the door they shot her
by accident okay
this this whole notion being promoted by
the biden administration
it is a lie that america is endemically
racist it is a lie that america's
founding principles
are shot through with racism they're
explicitly couched in universal human
terms
that is why the united states has been
able to adapt to a more diverse
population
it's why the united states has become
one of the most racially tolerant places
on planet earth on planet earth do you
know where
black people on planet earth have the
highest household income
wait for it the united states it is not
close okay but the idea is that the
united states
every part of the united states is shot
through with racism because the bigger
you can make the crisis the more deep
you can make the crisis in america's
soul
the more you need the heavy hand of
government to cure it
this is the real pitch that biden is
making see if there's one thing that
unites biden's agenda throughout his
career it's the government can solve the
problem and if you want bigger
government which is what joe biden wants
he wants more control he wants more
control over your life
he wants his administration to have more
control over the things you do every day
over the systems under which you live
but in order to justify that you better
have some sort of crisis that you can
cite so there are many types of crisis
that joe biden has attempted to cite in
just his first few months in office he's
attempted to use covet as a crisis even
though it's on the wane
which is why you've seen his entire
scientific establishment embracing
false nonsense about how the vaccines
are not all that effective and after you
have them you can't go to a restaurant
and all this
he's attempted to play up the coveted
crisis in its waning days
so that he can ram through four trillion
dollars in spending and then call it
infrastructure
right you've seen him play up the crisis
of climate change
right now it's a climate emergency we
have to do something if we don't do
something then it's going to be the day
after tomorrow dennis quaid is going to
be wandering through the streets of
brooklyn
trailed by a tsunami of ice this kind of
crisis nonsense
and now you're getting the crisis at the
heart of america's soul
okay here is the thing the united states
elected a black president twice
that does say something about the united
states the current vice president of the
united states is a black woman
the united states again has the highest
household income for black people of any
country on planet earth
and the notion that the united states is
deeply shot through with racism
it is a lie it is a lie that is
specifically designed in order to
promote
the ability of people like joe biden to
control all the aspects of your life and
it's being promoted
day in and day out by this
administration
it's why you have joe biden himself
captain moderate out there saying things
like parts of our country are
backsliding into jim crow
name the part of the country and how
anything they are doing right now looks
like jim crow you can't because it's an
abject lie it is disgusting i'm sorry
it's a moral outrage that joe biden is
suggesting that georgia is sliding back
into jim crow georgia currently has a
black senator
stacey abrams is maybe the most powerful
political figure in georgia right now
black americans have been outvoting
their share of the population in georgia
in the last couple of elections
what in the hell is he talking about
sliding back into like is he
he should know what jim crow is he's old
enough to remember it he's old enough to
have negotiated and been friends with
people who are in favor of jim crow was
joe biden
how dare he suggest that 43 states
across america attempting to
attempting to verify electoral
information amounts to a new form of jim
crow
it is a lie but again the lie is
designed for a purpose and the purpose
is
top down control the larger you can make
people think the crisis is the more
they're willing to hand this dollaring
old control of their lives
here is joe biden being a doddering old
and a morally abysmal one at that
parts of our country are backslidded
into the days of jim
crow passing laws that hearken back to
the era of poll taxes
when black people were made to guess how
many beans
how many jelly beans in a jar or count
the number of bubbles in a bar of soap
before they could
cast their ballot again he says this to
al sharpton's group again al sharpton
one of the great race baiters in
american history
what the actual f is he talking about
can he name a law
that looks like anyone in america being
forced to guess the number of jelly
beans in hr to vote
can you name anything remotely like that
of course it cannot because it's a lie
it is not true where's the
where's the fact check on this where's
politifact on this i know politifact
will fact-check tim kennedy
for the great sin of suggesting that
totalitarian regimes seek gun control
which happens to be true
but they're not going to fact-check joe
biden for saying for months that jim
crow is happening
that america is racist in its from its
inception that america's dna
is rooted in this stuff and that right
now in america there are people who want
black people to have to guess the number
of bubbles in a jar in order to vote
but it's just a lie it's just a lie and
your media
who are gaslighting the living hell out
of you they're telling you that they are
the fact checkers they are the people
you should trust no wonder no one trusts
the media because they are just the pr
wing of this garbage administration
it's so vile okay what he is doing is
immoral it is immoral to suggest that
your fellow americans are in favor of
jim crow because they disagree with you
about voter id
and it is it is even more immoral to use
those lies as the predicate
for an assault on individual rights and
free market economics which is exactly
what joe biden is doing
and it's throughout his administration
we'll get to more of this in just one
second
first let's talk about the fact that my
kids been keeping me up all hours of the
night that means i need
my coffee need it right now and that is
why i love
black rifle coffee black rifled coffee
is delivering your daily dose of freedom
one delicious cup at a time black rifle
coffee company is a veteran-owned coffee
company serving premium coffee to people
who love america
veteran ceo and founder evan hafer spent
over seven years on the ground overseas
with u.s special forces
and as a cia contractor haven't even
modified his gun trucks during the
invasion of a rock to grind coffee
anywhere with the companies buy a bag
give a bag campaign they make sure to
give the gift of america's coffee to
those that serve around the globe in
2020 they donated over six million cups
of coffee with every purchase you make
black rifle gives back black rifle
imports their
high quality coffee beans from all over
the world and roasts five days a week at
their facilities in tennessee and utah
the team at black rifle coffee they're
continually researching experimenting
with new roasting methods and coffee
origins
i know the guys who run black rifle
coffee they are awesome dudes i've hung
out with them
true patriots awesome people go to
blackriflecoffee.com stop giving your
money
by the way to a bunch of coffee
companies hate your guts instead give it
to blackriflecoffee.com get 20
off your purchase that is
blackriflecoffee.com
shapiro go check them out right now okay
so it is not
just joe biden himself or his un
ambassador who promote this
bizarre notion that america is racist in
all of its institutions
it's also people he's attempting to put
in positions of power
with regard to the legal structure of
the american government so kristin clark
is joe biden's nominee for assistant
attorney general
of the united states and she is
as far as i'm aware a race baiter par
excellence
she just anything she doesn't like
becomes racist this is the new mantra of
the democratic party by the way anything
i do like is infrastructure anything i
don't like is racist
how racist is christian clark well she
once argued that the human brain was
structured in a way that makes black
people superior to white people and that
quote human mental processes in the
brain
have chemicals that imbue one race with
superior physical and mental abilities
and spiritual abilities
clark claims that this racist diatribe
was mocking the controversial book the
bell curve
but clark also happened to invite a
holocaust denying fraud named anthony
martin then a professor at wellesley
college
to speak at harvard around the same time
clark was writing unrecognizable satire
about black supremacy she was calling
martin an intelligent well-versed black
intellectual who bases into information
on indisputable fact that's weird
because he wrote a book called
this guy wrote a textbook called the
secret relationship between blacks and
jews which blame jews for the slave
trade and also wrote the jewish
onslaught
published by a nation of islam leader
louis farrakhan
her notion that she was pending these
these
letters on race as sort of a parody of
the bell curve is about as plausible as
her assertion today in front of the
senate that her newsweek op-ed titled i
prosecuted police killings defund the
police but be strategic wasn't
actually about defunding the police
okay in 2019 she signed a letter
supporting
tamika mallory the louis farrakhan
supporting women's march co-founder who
asserted that black
the jewish people bore a special
collective responsibility as exploiters
of black and brown people
now kristen clarke could have made the
case in her hearings that she's moved
beyond her youthful
hijinks she didn't actually make that
case and in fact the truth is that
kristen clarke is a racial radical
senator tom cotton of arkansas
questioned her about her viewpoint on
michael brown
if she is such a racial moderate now if
she has moved beyond the radicalism of
the past
why is it that years after it has been
conclusively determined that michael
brown was not unjustifiably shot
by officer darren wilson in ferguson
missouri and that hands up don't shoot
was a lie
why is it that kristen clark continues
to maintain the fiction that michael
brown was shot
for reasons of race gunned down by a
white police officer for no reason
i'm asking you a simple factual question
was officer darren wilson
justified or not in the shooting of
michael brown in ferguson missouri
in 2014. based on the facts that i know
i'm not privy to the details that the
federal government may have been privy
to
in the course of its investigation as a
private citizen there is something
that feels unfair well michael you
obviously do not want to take the
position
the shooting was justified despite what
eric holder and vanita gupta have said
given the fact that you won't answer the
simple question yes or no
i mean it's just incredible so that
person is a person that joe biden wants
to be the assistant attorney general of
the united states but don't worry guys
they're not politicizing the the doj in
any way by the way here's a list of
things that kristen clarke has called
racist
senator mike lee my friend from utah
here he is going
after kristen clarke's claims of racism
pretty much everything in american life
ms clark i want to read a non-exhaustive
list of
of um elements of the american society
elements that you have at one point or
another described in the past as racist
police departments federal agencies
airbnb
election laws designed to combat fraud
the workplace
america's dna the virginia military
institute
the health care industry federal courts
and the department of justice
okay um and now she's gonna go work at
the department of justice where she has
worked before
so no this is not a radical
administration in any way again the idea
here is that if you create crises a
crisis of the soul american racism
a crisis of the economy inequality a
crisis of
global climate change a crisis in terms
of covenant then you can do whatever the
hell you want
and it justifies any sort of crazy
action which is why you are seeing
democrats
introducing legislation i kid you not to
expand the supreme court
they're doing it house and senate
democrats are introducing legislation
today
to expand the number of supreme court
justices to 13 from 9.
i wonder why 13 why why 13 could it be
because right now there are six
republican appointees on the court
and they just want to appoint four
democrats could it be that could it be
they want to outnumber the republican
appointees on the court seven to six
or uh probably not probably it's just
you know objectively they think 13 is
better than nine for no reason at all
it's time to shift the number of supreme
court justices for the first time in
like a century and a half
and we should do that for sure just for
no real reason guys i mean we just
kind of should probably the radical
power grab being attempted by the
democratic party on the basis of false
crises that do not
exist is astonishing right now it's
astonishing if you fall for it you're a
damned sucker
we'll get to more of this in just one
second first
let's talk about the fact that if you
ever get carsick or
been hungover pretty terrible feeling
nausea not a lot of fun well my wife
tends to get carsick a lot which is why
we've been using relief band it's the
number one fda cleared anti-nausea
wristband that has been clinically
proven to quickly relieve and
effectively prevent
nausea and vomiting associated with
motion sickness anxiety migraines
hangovers morning sickness chemotherapy
and so
much more the product is 100 drug-free
non-drowsy provides all-natural relief
with zero side effects for as long as
needed
the technology was originally developed
over 20 years ago in hospitals to
relieve nausea from patients but now
through a leaf band it's available to
the masses how it works relief band
stimulates the nerve in the wrist it
travels to the part of the brain that
controls nausea then it blocks the
signal your brain is sending to your
stomach
telling you that you're sick relief band
is the only over-the-counter wearable
device that has been used in hospitals
and oncology clinics to treat nausea and
vomiting if you know somebody who deals
with nausea a leaf band makes a terrific
gift my wife has been using it because
pretty much every time we drive she gets
car sick
as the world's opening back up don't let
the fear of nausea keep you sidelined
right now
relief band has an exclusive offer just
for ben shapiro listeners if you go to
reliefband.com and use promo code
shapiro you will receive 20
off plus free shipping and no questions
asked 30 day money back guarantee so you
got nothing to lose head on over to
relief band
r-e-l-i-e-f-b-a-n-d
dot com use our promo code shapiro for
20 off plus free shipping
okay so democrats are now attempting to
expand the supreme court
they've been talking about this for a
while it's not going to go anywhere
because it requires
basically a filibuster-proof majority
there's nothing here that is even
remotely connected with reconciliation
this is not a budget bill
so to require a filibuster-proof
majority which they're not going to get
the bill led by senator ed markey
democrat of massachusetts and
representative jerry nadler
of new york is the first legislation in
recent years designed to add seats to
the high court
its introduction comes as progressive
organizations are pushing for court
expansion
after watching senate republicans fill
three supreme court vacancies in four
years
under donald trump brian fallon former
hillary clinton aide
executive director of the liberal group
demand justice said the bill represents
quote a new era where democrats finally
stopped conceding the supreme court to
republicans
i do love the revisionist history where
the supreme court has been a bulwark in
favor of conservatism
in the last 10 years we have found out
that the supreme court believes that
same-sex marriage is mandated by the
constitution of the united states and
that the civil rights act of 1965
covers men who believe they are women
these are things this what a bulwark the
supreme court has been guys
incredible incredible working there
president joe biden has said that he is
not a fan of the idea
instead the white house announced last
week the creation of a bipartisan
commission now is this really going
anywhere no but it is a signal of where
democrats would go
if they actually had the power to do so
which is why you should never give them
the power to do so
and again all of this is predicated on
the lie that america's systems are
thoroughly corrupt and need to be torn
out at the root
and this is the widespread feeling in
the democratic party
there's a reason why if you ever see
polls of how people feel about their own
party
democrats are always highly satisfied
with their own party while republicans
are always highly dissatisfied with
their own party the reason is because
republicans
look to the republican party and say why
aren't you cutting government
why aren't you defunding planned
parenthood why aren't you doing the
million things that you have said that
you will do
democrats look at the democratic party
and they say i know that you promised us
the moon
but the truth is you're at least trying
to get there we see what the utopian end
goal is
and you guys are trying to get there
this is why democrats always come home
in a way that republicans very often do
not
and one of the things that's that's sort
of amazing about the democratic party
is that for all of the talk about how
republicans are terrible at ousting
radicals from their own ranks and stuff
republicans got rid of steve king
republicans didn't elect roy moore can
you find
a ah democrat in congress he's still in
congress because i think max rose is no
longer in congress can you find a
democrat in congress who's willing to
say
nary a word a word at all about recited
talib or elenor and the fact that
they're blatant anti-semites
are you willing to find a democrat
anywhere in america i'm talking about
state rank and file democratic voter
to acknowledge the anti-semitism problem
inside the democratic party
to acknowledge that hanging out with
louis farrakhan is actually a bad look
to acknowledge that joe biden is adult
or you can find a lot of republicans who
will say bad things about their own
politicians you never get it from
democrats ever why
because they all have the same utopian
goal and unless they're
liberal-minded democrats who are willing
to stand up to the radicalism inside
their own party this is just
going to continue because even the most
radical people in the democratic party
the people who the mainstream democrats
sort of taught it's not that they see
those people
as doing something bad it's not that
they see those people as having bad
principles
it's that they see the most radical
among them as just too committed to the
cause they're just too committed
it's the same way they look at antifa
rioters in portland or black lives
matter rioters
in every major city in the united states
you know it's not that they are doing
bad things or believe bad things or
are acting based on false information no
it's that they're just too committed
they're just too ideologically pure so
long as that's the take of the
democratic party we're in serious
trouble
we'll get some more of that in just one
second first let's talk about the fact
that you spend a lot of time in front of
screens i spend a lot of time in front
of screens
you get real headaches if you spend too
much time in front of screens this is
why you need a pair of felix gray
glasses felix gray glasses filter 15
times more blue light from screens than
other clear
blue light lenses high quality frame
materials make felix grey durable
super lightweight they can be adjusted
to fit the original optical lenses
relieve most
eye strain symptoms from daily screen
time and the more advanced sleep glasses
relieve serious daily eye strain and
were especially designed for late night
screen time
to improve sleep which is a big thing
for me i i pop on those felix
ray glasses if i'm gonna watch tv before
going to bed which i very often have to
do because i have like 15 minutes to
relax between the time my children go to
bed in the time i have to go to bed
felix gray frames our hand finish from
italian acetate making them durable
lightweight super comfortable
blue light lenses come standard starting
at 95 bucks or add your prescription at
checkout starting at 145 bucks
if you don't love your glasses in the
first 30 days their in-house customer
care team will take care of exchanges
and returns no hassle
and no questions asked felix spray
glasses they're designed for the 21st
century go to felix grayglasses.com shop
glasses
that work as hard as you do that is
felix grayglasses.com
ben felix g-r-a-y glasses.com men free
shipping free exchanges 30-day
money-back guarantee you got nothing to
lose felix grayglasses.com
ben okay so when i say that the
democratic party is willing to tolerate
its own radicals
because they think that those people are
well intentioned and have only the best
ideas
let me point out james clyburn so james
clyburn who's a person who said radical
things on his own
he is a person who helped elect joe
biden president i think it is safe to
say that if james clyburn did not exist
bernie sanders would have been the
democratic party nominee
it was james clyburn who motivated the
voting base in south carolina during the
democratic party
primaries to push biden in that super
tuesday
super tuesday it really was super for
biden it elevated him above bernie who
had all the momentum
so clever was asked about the fact that
rashida talib has now called for ending
the police
i rescued it to leave in the aftermath
of the dante right shooting in
minneapolis said it's time to
essentially abolish policing and
incarceration by the way
which good luck with that so james
clyburn who's a much more
responsible politician was asked about
this and instead of him saying that's
crazy what the hell is she talking about
he says
i understand the passion i understand
where she's coming from whenever
democrats talk about
aoc or issue to leave or elena omar it's
always with the tone of sort of
what my cute but slightly wayward
mischievous child and
you know they really just they're just
so pure and innocent of heart
and maybe they'll learn to be a little
more practical as time goes on here's
the thing
if you don't if you don't excise the
radicalism now
it is absolutely infectious and it is
infecting the rest of the democratic
party here's james clyburn
you have efforts to get this george
floyd justice and policing act
passed to get it through the senate and
it's going to be an uphill climb do you
think her comments hurt the cause though
no i don't think they do i think she's
expressing her frustrations
and what she hears from her constituents
and i can understand that
but we need to pass this just in the
policing act
just because it gives us
the kind of tools that we need to deal
with police officers who are not good
okay part of the game here that's played
by the mainstream democratic politicians
is you see these these
you know these rabid radicals on our
left here you know they have all the
right intentions but you don't really
want them controlling you
you want us controlling you so what you
really need is for us to pass a bill
like this so we have the tools we'll
protect you
from these crazies but also the crazies
they're not that crazy i mean like you
understand where they're coming from
okay now here is the reality oh this is
built on the lie that america's policing
is shot through with systemic racism so
let's talk about that for just one
second because since we've been using
anecdotal evidence rather than data to
support this bizarre position
let's use some anecdotal evidence okay
so here is what happened
in the dante wright case so dante wright
resists arrest he's pulled over
he was this arrest he was apparently
a person with a pretty serious criminal
history for example
and so the police may have known that
when they ran his license plate and when
they pulled him over
in any case he decided it would be a
wise idea to resist arrest and jump
back into his car as it turns out this
was not a wise idea but beyond that
he was in fact the victim of a piece of
police abuse
right the the officer in question meant
to shoot him with a taser and instead
shot him with a gun and he died okay now
what is the what is the logical outcome
of that the logical outcome of that is
that the police officer has now been
arrested
the police officer has been arrested her
name is kim potter she's been arrested
and she's probably gonna go to jail for
manslaughter okay that
is the predictable outcome of how a
justice system should work and she's
going to manslaughter
she's going for manslaughter even though
again
the idea from the left is that that
dante wright is a completely innocent
wonderful human being
two things can be true at once one dante
wright could have been a career criminal
who tried to run away from the police
and two the police still should not have
shot him with a gun
she should have used it hazer and if you
mistake your taser for your gun and go
to jail for manslaughter both those
things can be true
by the way on the dante right criminal
history the daily mail is reporting that
he choked a woman and threatened to
shoot her if she didn't hand over 820
bucks she had stuffed in her bra
court papers obtained by the daily mail
allege that's the case that led to a
warrant for his arrest at the time he
was shot and killed by the officer
kimberly potter in minnesota on sunday
leading to days of unrest apparently he
was pulled over for having expired
license plate tags
although he called his mom and told her
it was for having an air freshener
hanging on his rear view mirror
while checking his details they learned
of the warrant so
it turns out that that may have in fact
affected the police officers
more aggressive behavior but bottom line
is what happened in that particular case
if america's justice system were truly
racist then the idea here would have
been
everything's fine everything's fine but
you know what happened
the officer is probably gonna go to jail
according to media the minnesota police
officer who fatally shot 20 year old
dante wright an unarmed black man pulled
over for driving an suv with expired
license plates will be charged with
second-degree manslaughter
the brooklyn police officer kim potter
is a 26-year veteran of the department
if convicted she faces up to 10 years in
prison or a fine of up to 20 000
she did resign from her job the brooklyn
police and the brooklyn center police
chief also
resigned on tuesday okay so does that
sound like an abjectly racist system
seriously does it does it sound like a
super racist system that the police
officer
who shot a man who resisted arrest
at being out on a warrant for
threatening to kill a woman with a gun
to steal money from her the police
officer who mistook a taser for a gun
is gonna go to jail now as presumably
she should based on the available
evidence
does that sound like a deeply unjust
racially biased system
let me put on the table another story
for you okay ashley babbitt
is the woman who was killed during the
january 6th right she's the only person
we know of who's directly killed during
the january 6th riot we still don't know
how officer brian sicknick died
he did not die at the at the place he
was not hit in the head with it with a
an emergency fire piece of me
with it with a fire extinguisher uh that
that story turns out not to have been
true as far as we are aware
so that means that the only person who
was directly killed during the january
sixth riot
was in fact ashley babbitt who was by
all accounts unarmed right ashley
babbitt was climbing through
a a broken piece of window uh to invade
the capitol building
and a police i mean it's all on tape a
police officer who is inside a door
shot up at her and killed her right that
is the story of ashley babbitt
now we are learning that an
investigation conducted by the u.s
attorney's office for the
district of columbia determined there is
insufficient evidence to support a
criminal prosecution of the officer in
question
we still by the way don't know the
identity of the officer in question we
do in the
in the minnesota case right we knew the
identity of the officer like pretty much
right away
authorities had considered for months
whether criminal charges were
appropriate for the capitol police
officer who fatally shot
abbott the doj's decision though
expected officially closes out the
investigation
prosecutors said they had reviewed video
of the shooting along with statements
from the officer involved and other
officers and witnesses
examined physical evidence from the
scene and reviewed the autopsy results
as well okay so let me just put it this
way if ashley babbitt had him in a black
person
associated with black lives matter and
been shot by a cop unarmed in this way
there would have been riots is there any
doubt about this
i would really i'd love to hear the
counter argument on this
if the officer had then been let go if
they'd said you know what
justified she was she was unarmed and
she was climbing through a window and an
officer shot her
do you think that people in the media
would be like oh no problem
it's fine and if you see the reaction
from the left that is the reaction from
the left the reaction left is ashley
babbitt had it coming because she was a
january 6th rioter
but as we have found out over the course
of the last year you can be a black
lives matter rioter and go loot and burn
things
and the media will treat you as though
you are some sort of racial justice hero
it's pretty incredible stuff so if we're
talking about the bias in the system
i'm not seeing it there i'm not seeing
the racial bias in the officer who
shoots ashley babbitt no problem
the officer who shot dante wright is
charged for manslaughter that doesn't
look like racial bias to me
that looks like either objective justice
being done
or like maybe a little bit of racial
sensitivity running
in favor of the uh running against the
white woman who got shot because that
woman had been black i think that the
story would be completely different
in the capital riots and this plays into
the floyd case as well
into the george floyd case we have heard
from every member of the democratic
party that the george floyd case
is a case of american racial bias i ask
you
any evidence of this seriously any
evidence george floyd
was high as a kite he was resisting
arrest other people in his car
were telling him stop resisting arrest
george they tried to deal with him for
45 minutes
he pushed his own way out of the car he
was shouting i can't breathe before he
was out of the car
and and yet somehow this has to do with
race and racism
and not only that the media treat it as
just unquestionable that it had to do
with race
and racism well here's the problem
what's going to happen
if derek chovin i keep saying this what
happens if derek shoving gets acquitted
or what happens if there's just a hung
jury riots rights are what's going to
happen
we'll get to the latest in the show of
in trial because that continues the pace
we'll get to that in just one second
first
let us talk about the simple fact that
there are a lot of dudes who are dealing
with issues that they don't actually
want to talk to a doctor about because
they're embarrassed about but here's the
thing if you got a medical issue you
ought to go get it solved no matter what
it is
that includes something like erectile
dysfunction with roman you get a free
online evaluation and
ongoing care for ed all from the comfort
and privacy of your home
a us licensed healthcare professional
will work with you to find the best
treatment plan if medication is
appropriate
it ships to you free with two day
shipping the whole process is
straightforward and discreet getting
started is simple just go to
getroman.com
ben complete an online visit take care
of your ed without leaving your home
complete an online visit today to
connect with a healthcare professional
and have it
taken care of go to getroman.com right
now you get 15 bucks off your first
month
it's time to take care of that id i mean
if you've got an easy solution here guys
why not just go take care of it
remember get started today you'll save
15 bucks on your first order of
ed treatment that is getroman.com right
now for 15 bucks off
g-e-t r-o-m-a-n dot com slash band right
now
you get 15 off your first month of ed
treatment you got a problem go get it
solved get roman.com
ben for the special offer okay in just
one second we're gonna get to the latest
in the chauvin trial
and then we'll get to our garbage
activist media which is
complicit they in fact are the main
drivers of the propaganda effort
aimed at the heart of the united states
and its principles
we'll get some more of this in one
second first it's already episode five
and i know that you can't get enough of
candace owns or her brand new show
candace if you haven't checked it out i
don't know what you're waiting for
candace hosts a lively series of guests
each week for a discussion panel
interviews
and her signature cancel corner that's
my favorite part of the show this week
she hosts my friend adam carolla who is
awesome
tune in you're not going to want to miss
their conversation the show streams on
fridays 9 pm eastern 8 pm central at
dailywire.com but you can get the audio
podcast canvas
on apple spotify or wherever you listen
to your podcast right now so if you need
some candice owens in your podcast feed
look no further head on over to apple
podcaster spotify subscribe today
be sure to leave a five star review if
you like what you hear you're listening
to the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
alrighty so meanwhile in the derek
shoving case it's becoming increasingly
clear each and every day that
at the very least reasonable doubt would
be justified
that would certainly be a justified
finding by the jury the defense is
laying out its case
basically this thing has turned into
what the wall street journal is terming
a clash of experts
according to the wall street journal the
murder trial of derek shoving has
shifted into a battle of expert
testimony in its final days with a
forensic pathologist testifying for
defense wednesday that george floyd died
of cardiac arrest because of heart
disease and the death couldn't even be
ruled a homicide the testimony from
david fowler
the former chief medical examiner for
the state of maryland contradicted
prosecution expert
and buttressed chauvin's defense that
drugs and health problems doomed at the
46-year-old floyd and not the former
minneapolis police officer kneeling on
him in the prone position for nine
minutes
i mean frankly i find that much more
plausible
right fowler said that that he died of
cardiac arrhythmia that seems much more
plausible
my my colleague matt walsh had a good
thought experiment let's say
that you had a choice today between
taking the amount of fentanyl
and meth that was in george floyd's
system or having a 140 pound man with 40
pounds of gear
kneel on your shoulder for nine minutes
which ones do you choose
also having a 75 artery blockage
which which one of those things do you
choose either all the health conditions
on the one hand or a guy kneeling on
your back
for nine minutes 49 seconds a good
thought experiment doesn't mean that
it's just positive
but to pretend that george floyd's prior
health conditions
we already have testimony that he had
been hospitalized
for for an overdose just a few months
before
we have the medical examiner the
original medical examiner suggesting
that if he found george floyd dead in
his apartment he immediately would have
ruled it as
an overdose you know the like reasonable
doubt when it comes to causation
seems like a minimum here almost here's
the defense medical examiner david
fowler saying floyd died of cardiac
arrhythmia
did you form in your opinion to a
reasonable degree of medical certainty
which you thought was the principal
cause of mr floyd's death
yes and what is that cardiac arrhythmia
due to hypertensive atherosclerotic
cardiovascular disease
during restraint okay he didn't just say
that
he also added that this notion that that
prone position makes you unable to
breathe is just not true
cops routinely use the prone position on
people it does not mean that you die
in certain situations people are
examined in the prone position
there are therapeutic maneuvers where
people are
deliberately placed in the prone
position
one of the best examples right now is
covert where patients will be
put in a prone position which is face
down and
it improves their ability for
oxygen exchange
not decreases it so
you know the prone position by itself um
does not have or at least there is no
evidence right now that that is a
significant issue
so fowler said that it was not a
profound low oxygen state induced by the
police
via subdual restraint and positional
asphyxia that caused floyd's hard to
stop
he said instead it was floyd's
exceptionally fragile physiological
condition
a condition unknowable to the arresting
officers according to legal insurrection
according to the defense narrative it
was floyd's own physiological fragility
that killed him when he chose to subject
himself to the justified use of force
by police officers compelling his
compliance with lawful arrests including
his forcible 10-minute struggle with
multiple police officers
and subsequent restraint this
again makes a fair bit of common sense
the reality is that the medical examiner
that was brought forth last week
by the by the prosecution the testimony
that they could tell just from the tape
alone that the cause of death i find
that
almost impossible to believe i find that
really really difficult to believe i'm
not the only one there are legal
analysts on core tv
we've had them on the program talking
about this i've never seen anything
remotely like that in a courtroom
somebody suggesting that they can watch
a videotape and determine cause of death
had nothing to do with drugs
simply by watching somebody breathe on
tape from a distance of 10 to 15 feet
like i i
it's a magical ability if that is the
case feller looked at the autopsies
fowler looked at the available
information
he said you know one thing that is
worthwhile noting here is that the
defense is that the prosecution has
completely shifted its case
which by the way it has originally the
prosecution case was that it was
it was chauvin's knee on the neck that
cut off the circulation
of oxygen to the brain and thereby
killed george floyd then it turned out
that the defense had pretty good
evidence that in fact chauvin was not
on his neck for 9 minutes 49 seconds not
only that
chauvin was not using the kind of hold
in any case
that actually cuts off oxygen to the
brain in fact this is what the medical
examiner testified yesterday fowler
based upon your review of the video
in this case did you observe
mr shovin's knee obstructing the
carotid artery of mr floyd
that knee did not obstruct either
carotid artery
and even if it had obstructed one the
carotid artery on the other side plus
the two
vertebral arteries would continue to
supply the brain with
enough blood for it to function okay so
here's the bottom line if chauvin ends
up in a hung jury there will be riots
and we all know there will be riots and
everybody's preparing
for riots and that's why the media love
this particular case you may notice that
as soon as a case
is disposed of with the officer going to
jail it's just
it's not it's never a headline again
it's just not noticed when you have
walter scott in south carolina who shot
in the back by a police officer running
away and the police officer then
drops a gun next to the body and then
that police officer goes to jail
for murder that does not become a riot
why because
it's pretty obvious what happened
everybody agrees what happened and the
officer goes to jail
in the case of of dante wright what
you're going to see is if the officer is
tried and convicted
there will be no riots right in
uncontroversial cases are not the ones
that media love
the media love the controversial cases
because what they like to do is impute
bad intention
to people who actually look at the
evidence and this is all part and parcel
again
of driving that crisis mentality america
is in a state of constant crisis and if
you don't take a side then you are on
the side of evil
and this is being driven by the media in
an act of activism
that that is just it's clear activism
this is not journalism in any way
the new york times has now printed a
piece of quote-unquote journalism it's
not journalism
it's basically mccarthyite lists it's
from andrew ross sorkin
jason carrion sarah kessler michael j
zelimer said lauren hirsch and a frat
leaveni
okay so it's 87 people writing for the
new york times the ceos who didn't sign
a big defense of
voting rights hundreds of leaders and
companies signed a letter opposing
strict limits
they did not does it sound like activism
or journalism to you when somebody
doesn't sign a letter when's the last
time that was news
there's a collective letter i didn't
sign it was there a letter on all the
people who didn't sign the harper's
weekly letter was there was there like a
big
story about that no the goal here is to
pressure all of these corporations and
to pretend that they are in favor of
voter suppression
and the new joe biden-esque jim crow
if they don't do exactly what the new
york times wants them to do our media
are just the activist propaganda wing of
the democratic party at this point
and they are the ones who are pushing
forward into the private sphere all of
the lies being told by the democratic
party
here's the new york times amazon
blackrock google warren buffett and
hundreds of other companies and
executives have signed a new statement
opposing any discriminatory legislation
that would make it harder for people to
vote
the statement which ran as a two-page ad
in the new york times comes amid a
flurry of voting related proposals from
republicans who have generated competing
calls for corporations to take a stand
and to stay out of politics unless
lawmakers retaliate
just as notable as the names who signed
the statement are those that didn't
those evil corporations staying out of
political matters that don't involve
them
those evil nasty corporations not doing
what the new york times tells them to do
there are some notable omissions says
the new york times many companies
declined to sign the statement
some executives such as warren buffett
signed for themselves but not on behalf
of their companies
coca-cola and delta declined to add
their names perhaps fearing more
blowback for earlier statements and also
not feeling the need to speak again
jpmorgan chase declined to sign the
statement despite a personal request
from senior black business leaders to
jamie dimon who made a statement on
voting rights before
doug mcmillan walmart's ceo who also
chairs the business roundtable lobby
group sent a note to employees to
explain the company's position he said
we're not in the business of partisan
politics while our government relations
teams have historically focused on core
business issues like tax policy
or government regulation walmart and
other major employers are increasingly
being asked to weigh in on broader
societal issues such as civil rights
the company didn't sign the statement
but we do want to be clear we believe
broad participation and trust in the
election process
are vital to its integrity so they're
all going to be bullied into speaking on
topics that have nothing to do with
their companies and that are
controversial at the very least
and the media are just going to push
this stuff they're going to push it as
hard as they possibly can
the virtue signaling will continue until
america is all better which is why you
get
ben and jerry's announcing that they
don't like the police anymore so free
ice cream for everybody gang
seems to me that if ben and jerry's
doesn't like the police next time
somebody robs ben and jerry's
they have nobody to call quote the
murder of dante wright murder
not manslaughter murder of dante wright
is rooted in white supremacy
again what's the evidence this is rooted
in white supremacy and results from the
intentional criminalization
of black and brown communities
i mean again dante wright shouldn't have
been shot also dante wright was a
criminal
that's not intentional criminalization
of dante wright the man was a criminal
there's a warrant out for him and he
resisted arrest
says ben and jerry's the system can't be
reformed it must be dismantled
a real system of public safety rebuilt
from the ground up okay i look forward
to to all of the free ice cream for
everyone meanwhile coke is realizing
that they have made a very large mistake
coca-cola is now striking a conciliatory
tone after coming under pressure from
conservatives according to the
washington examiner which shows that
there is hope moving forward for
conservatives and that is stand up on
your hind legs and stop
giving into this crap the soda giant
based in atlanta was
absent from that list of more than 500
corporations and individuals that signed
a statement condemning any election
legislation that would quote unquote
restrict voters from having quote an
equal and fair opportunity to cast
a ballot coca-cola said that the company
had not seen the letter but it's
certainly open to hearing their
perspective
they said quote we believe the best way
to make progress now is for everyone to
come together to listen respectfully
share concerns and collaborate on a path
forward we remain open to productive
conversations with advocacy group and
lawmakers who may have
differing points of view why because
they felt it in the pocketbook
right that's all that happened here they
felt it directly in the pocketbook
and this is true of all of these
corporations they're all virtue
signaling because they know that the
left is attempting to eat them
that's all by the way this is also true
for some of your favorite places like
the nba
it turns out that the nba according to
clay travis's outkick
has been outsourcing to chinese
companies who acknowledge that they've
been using
slave labor cotton this is according to
clay travis
so the same people who are virtue
signaling at you about how america is a
terrible horrible no good very bad
racist place
that same league they're pushing
companies that overtly engage in muslim
slave labor
according to clay travis's outkick he'll
be joining the show a little bit later
on
today okay so should we push back on
this of course we should push back on
this and
there will be success if we do push back
on this this is the point
the left is pushing and they are pushing
they're pushing they're pushing a false
narrative about you
they say that you are a racist if you
believe in america's systems they're
pushing a false narrative about
america's founding principles and
they're using that as a fake crisis in
order to ram through
tremendous change to a system that is
not only functional as the greatest
system
created in the history of mankind so
it's time for the pushback
be part of the pushback don't be part of
the surrender caucus
all right we'll be back here later today
with an additional hour of content
coming up soon
the matt wall show airs at 1 30 pm
eastern be sure to check it out over at
dailywire.com i'm ben shapiro this is
the ben shapiro show ben shapiro show is
produced by elliot feld
executive producer jeremy boring our
supervising producer is mathis glover
and our assistant director is pavo
wydowsky editing is by adam scievitz
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant is jessica crans
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production
copyright daily wire 2021
on the matt welsh show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you
your family our country not just
politics but culture faith
current events all the fundamentals if
they matter to you come check out the
show